look at the air is the original
boom-boom tears you guys how are you
Jerry O'Connell from the cheerio show is
walking in what an honor guys for going
on the honor is ours well it is an honor
have any of you been to City field for a
Mets game I know I know mr. Brewer has
but I'm talking to I'm talking to Gina I
have a nice you are the star of of the
Mets it's really exciting to see he was
just talking about how Mets fans don't
think that he's a real fan because he
only puts out videos at certain times
yeah and he sounds doc Gooden coke I
shook mr. goodies hand outside a Citi
Field he was right there welcome back to
the Train such a nice job in being but
clearly as demons yeah coke yeah
Citi Field I want to say is maybe the
most magical baseball experience when
they play that Billy Joel song and
everybody links arms I went to that
World Series game that they won the only
one that they want to guess they're the
Royal Guard and when everybody linked
arms and sang piano man it was do they
do that is that your thing they do know
you know that III think they do whatever
game right they do I don't I think they
they do do it every single game the
seventh-inning Yankees YMCA and that
game maybe the Red Sox to sweet Karen
the Yankees do
that game to start off with Noah
syndergaard throwing the ball high over
the first batter's head right and there
was a boom wow it's uh so it's exciting
to meet the biggest Mets fan ever I
don't care what anyone says are you
imagining either um I do follow them
I do the Metropolitan's yeah I'm gonna
upset some people I do follow another
New York team a little nicely that's
fine but I root for both I do even worse
than choosing one over the other no it's
a disclosing so you voted for Trump and
Hillary for everybody don't you
um I root for New York teams I like to
see them a win yeah yeah who do you not
root for like who do you like to see
lose who's Jerry O'Connell go like it's
not what you're supposed to say before
you're trying to launch a television you
don't want to say anything bad I do it
does upset me that um um teams from
Boston in all leagues in all sports
I don't even follow the MLS but I'm sure
the Boston MLS team has won numerous
championships right and it's annoying
it's almost unfair you know what yeah
it's like the Red Sox guard like this a
tremendously long streak of never
winning a World Series and now it's like
okay you've had your fill it but it's
not only baseball it's also you know
their hockey teams in the finals this
season it's some it's just done course
it's almost like a you know like I don't
I I don't want to get too political but
like government's break up like large
companies they don't let like AT&T merge
with like I mean Boston has a monopoly
on sport you know you guys just barely
squeaked by Mirjam would Pandora and I
know it's indoor that was my joke but
it's um like someone has to break it up
up there it's not fair
no I get that hey are your wrestling
fans still making fun of me for not
getting into that pwg wrestling match
all this I did your show and I tried to
get into a wrestling match in Los
Angeles and it was sold out and I was
turned
and then there's this like independent
groove it like it called pro wrestling
guerrilla wait oh but I gotta give them
a shout-out it it's an incredible
experience if you're in I think that
it's just a Southern California thing
always in Reseda yeah yeah Anson Valley
I'll reseed is that where Daniel was
from wasn't that from the Karate Kid
yes yeah you're correct they have a
large mural thank you everywhere condoms
but remember that and Jerry O'Connell
showed up and he didn't have a ticket
you have to buy them away in advance
they sell out all the times it's a small
venue didn't try to get him for free I
tried to purchase a ticket today of but
unfortunately they line up outside
because it's also first come first serve
as far as the tickets go and a whole
line of fans got to see Jerry O'Connell
turned away at the door and they were
continually remind me of it on social
media like to tell you yeah I was there
when you couldn't get in and I did and I
refused to engage them because I don't
want to sort of beam or anything but I'd
still obsess over that I still obsess
over the comments and read them
humiliate you or how do you think it
hurts me did you try to tell him I went
trying to get him for free I wasn't
trying to know the buying tickets the
day of right I couldn't buy them online
and I thought I'd try my luck going
there and I didn't get in and the amount
owed started like jeering at me and
shaming you shaming me hurts you it
angers me gives you a fury well I get
that the over wrestling fans they don't
have that much opportunity to like yell
at a Hollywood celebrity and say we're
better than you because to that day they
were better than yeah and then I did
okay they were just earlier they had
nothing else to do a celebrity has other
things to do than stand on line Jim I
had nothing to do that I was like of
course they're gonna let me and I'm a
celebrity and they didn't and that's
really let's get to the heart of it
that's really
is that I'm not farther far enough of my
career where I can get into a really
local wrestling match probably didn't
thrill you that there's footage of sofia
vergara and joe megan yellow at a pwg
show is the real gillian jacobs yeah i
do want to show the way though i did for
the next match i did purchase a ticket
online and i had it and i went there
with the intent of saying to the same
people who cheered can see i'm in like
what are you gonna do about it now I'm
sort of getting in their faces and no
one said anything well you should align
and tour the ticket up and threw it on
the ground that's the old Jerry
O'Connell the new Jerry O'Connell is
much nicer much more relatable the Jerry
O'Connell host of the Jerry Oh show how
long did you in law school I want to ask
you that - how are you dropped an idea
we're gonna stop my thing a little lost
I dropped out after one year it was um
it was a mistake Jim I was oh my do you
want to do it um
you know what I uh my wife and I just
had kids and I was gonna take a couple
years off and my wife was working very
steadily in a TV show and I just
couldn't sit around and I went to night
school for a year and it was a mistake
you didn't like it it was - um what's
the word like hard no it was actually
really cool it was a fun um I could go
back someday I was really into it I mean
I realized when I was there I wasn't
gonna like finish like cool education
just to see how you know the legal
system works how lawyers have really I
mean it really I don't want to say they
run everything but everything we do is
touched by a lawyer you know I mean
everything everything and it sort of has
to be contracted you know and as dopey
is like you know um even like you know
traffic cones on the street when you're
coming here and they closed off a lane
they're digging a hole and
legally it's been decided you know these
are OSHA regulations decided by lawyers
we have to put cones around this and
close the lane because there's a
possibility of an accident and we have
to show that we took all the precautions
that we did against this against anyone
getting hurt lawyers touch everything
yeah they just touch everything but it's
designed like other lawyers designed it
so that lawyers haven't touch everything
you know I can't believe I'm defending
it but it does sort of make for um you
know order in society well the only
reason we don't do certain things right
I mean there's people I'd love to hit
with a wrench but I'll get sued so I
can't do it I mean that's assault to
slander people right you would love to
unleash yeah just defame somebody in an
article makeup use your words to destroy
a person oh I'd love to defend certain
horrible things there's a really funny
thing my boss Wendy Williams who has the
daytime show which she's my Oprah she's
putting me on her slot in all her
stations for the month of August she
does this funny thing whenever she tells
a story about someone she immediately
interrupts with allegedly allegedly
alleging and um it's funny you know
but there's a lawyer in the control room
um who has a button and it's an
allegedly button and cuz she works in
gossip and stuff and you know I'm gonna
have to do the same thing the same
lawyers gonna be saying there I'm gonna
talk about I don't know something ASAP
rocky did in Sweden and hitting someone
and that allegedly light will come on
and you have to say allegedly so above
is just say allegedly or is it like a
little red light and you all allegedly
says allegedly in red letters wow it's
pretty smart yeah cuz they knew like
this is that word
yeah and Wendy loves talking gossip so
just make sure that this is there and
yeah I feel like lawyer started way back
in the day and they were nerds that used
to get their ass kicked because the
order of life is just the Bruins always
ruled the roost yeah and then somewhere
along the way they started festering up
like you know I'll do it you
I don't know I'm gonna sit in ensuing
and they're suing it and it's gonna turn
back one day to just pure fight club I
don't care
sue me I'm gonna I'm gonna traumatize
you for life with one shot - underneath
your skull yeah fine I'm gonna lose
everything but you know what it's really
gonna be worth it cuz you're gonna be
right traumatized for life right I think
Brandon said three all the money in the
world
Brando hit that photographer the
paparazzi broke his jaw and they asked
him I think he said it's the best
$25,000 that we've come back I don't
know but it's definitely pushing in that
direction it's kind of worth going least
in my head I kind of sorts going to law
school to figure out how much people can
sue you for certain things right so you
can make a quick decision is it worth
the 25 grand
it was rough - looking like how much can
they - if I knew how grave them you know
how much you know where it gets shady is
um that emotional distress intentional
infliction of emotional distress price
on that you know he's nuts for a little
bit this person made me nuts right just
wild and and you know what really I'm
one of the first things I learned in a
class called torts which is what you
take when you go there is when you go to
any sort of trial and you're suing
someone you say it something that really
resonates with the courts and juries is
you say it has really affected your sex
life that you cannot make love anymore
it's gonna prove that you know in like
in an emotional distress sort of you
know in a in a courtrooms eyes is like a
really bad thing you have second these
picture your wife bullying juries love
to [ __ ] God right before I came here I'm
sorry I was a little late but um you
know we all moved here for to do this
cheerio show and you know I have my wife
and kids here and I'm working a lot and
my wife is not and we're in a place and
it has no cable TV or anything and
my wife was I got I went to the Apple
store yesterday and got that Apple TV
thing and I woke up this morning to come
here and my wife was like you you got a
hook up that application and I was like
I'll do it when I get back I gotta go
see um you know I gotta go to serious
and and my wife was like you can't you
can't not one more day I need this Apple
TV like I need it you you have to hook
it up and I was god it took me my
password wouldn't work ah forget it how
will the kids ten get a fire stick oh
really
kennefa someone gave me a fire set I get
a brand-new TV put anything on my should
I put Xfinity so I put cable so I put it
my neighbor neighbor goes Breuer to put
this fire stick in it hooked it up my
other nephew just went you get whatever
you want now what look how much strife
toupees nothing zero what did I get I
can get movies out now I get whatever TV
show I want I get Network TV I can get
box it whatever I want
I'm sure Jerry could tell you with his
year of law school that it's not
technically legal oh I didn't know the
fire stick is licensed legal the
software on the fire stick is less can't
squat doing that though no Mike is the
best now yeah you guys legally put all
kinds of weird [ __ ] on it there's no
protection on it it's great this is
gonna age me but remember you used to
get D scramblers and get sure the wh t
guy will not go home theater you know
you'd have the descrambler box you get
the free pay-per-view right right it's
the same principle same thing but with
anything and everything might have to I
mean I don't I just want to say on the
record legally I don't illegally
download any television whatsoever these
are all jokes together but I might want
to talk to your neighbor everybody I'm
looking at Jim's Sirius XM my ID by G
photo yeah it's a really good photo oh
yeah let me see I think smiling I'm a
during fatso know you're smiling you're
tan you're looking good are you in the
city
yeah I'm right let's move I'm right next
to Penn Station oh um a little busy over
there
no it's about say nice area um you know
what that Hudson Yards that new mall
went up that's pretty close walk through
I haven't been there I want to go to the
observation deck there's a building in
Hudson Yards supposed to a hundred
storey building it hasn't got a weird
like boomerang on the front like a
glass-bottom I want to go up and see
that's a good big observation deck um we
had our air conditioning didn't work
that week that it was unbearably hot so
no AC no cable TV no cable TV it's a new
place but my my family and I we were
sitting in that mall for about four days
pretty good Wi-Fi in there to stay cool
we would all bring our phones and
everything and just sit in the mall like
vagrants for these on is your family
very supportive of the Jerry Oh show
becoming a reality it seems like talk
daily a daytime talk has been something
that you've wanted to get involved in
for a long time you've done tons of
guest hosting you've done stuff with
Kelly Ripa you filled in for Wendy all
ton of time you know I was really in the
running to becoming America's Next Top
Model no I was in the running to helping
out Kelly Ripa with that um Kelly and
Ryan show and I did not get that job and
it's funny it was kind of um I guess it
was kind of depressing what I mean not
depressing I wasn't you know I was
coming out of my house but like um like
I publicly didn't get a job you know so
like you go to the supermarket and
everyone's like and it always happens
because it's a daytime audience it would
always happen at the supermarket for
some reason always in line because
you're trapped in line and some will go
hey excuse me and I go yeah and they go
you lost that's crazy Wow couldn't be
less helpful but your hands buying cat
food you know but I mean so there is
like um
it's not as I'm not kidding it's not the
anger I felt with the PWG comments right
but you do feel like uh God like don't
cry for me Argentina come here I'm
completely fine but it was really funny
I coalesced it for Wendy a bunch when he
took a little bit of a sabbatical and
then Fox and Wendy are doing this thing
where in August when a lot of TV shows
go dark meaning they show reruns they're
gonna try to test a show and they said
do you want to test and I was like huh
this will be a lot of fun I will say
this super tough because um wendy is a
single host so your opening segment is
20 minutes by yourself but the Wendy
folks loves you and your time so that's
got a but you know you guys as as
stand-ups will I mean kind of understand
my dilemma here every day I have to come
in and there are there is a group of
writers there but every day I come in at
7 a.m. and we go live at 10:00
you have to write a 22 minute monologue
don't they do that the night before it
typically comes from television that
aired or right so because it's a daily
show like um hey everybody welcome we're
gonna have a great show for you today 90
day fiancé
whoo it all went down last night the
families finally met up here we have a
clip and we'll show you how it went down
come back and then you have to write
like sort of comments on those clips
doesn't always have to be hilarious you
can just be about it it can be fun it
doesn't have to be it doesn't always
have to be funny I mean um but should be
entertaining it should be entertaining
you know it's um it's a it's an
interesting medium sure and you know in
the world of tell me when this is really
getting too boring I'm so sorry Beyonce
we love it
in the in the world of um yeah I know
you talk about it a lot oh yeah I know
it's silly really about me halter mom
when you had the bagel guy up here that
was a good smart guy really four feet
tall yeah but I'll sit on my tiptoes
when I took a photo with him just to
really really drive it home crazy
Peter Finch in network by the way do you
think it was justified the guy who
tackled him in that video no the guy was
the guy who he's being a dick by chess
Bobby but the guy and that guy in that
video would not have tackled him if he
was six four but it still did feel good
to see it happen yes it did yeah to
watch him tackled it made me feel the
people I was watching it with the first
time reacted negatively toward that man
tackle well he wouldn't have done this
if if Chris was a bigger guy that guy
never would have tackled him that's what
I hate about stuff like that I hope I
hope in Li laughed and cheered when I
saw on and making the entire room
uncomfortable and you don't know where
it's going in this day and age
ya know is he gonna pull something out
it's way out of line take them out 15
people here going is he implying a gun
is a wise yelling here's a look at take
them out saying out I tell people out of
it the day it's okay I didn't get the
job I would not be I would get them
going
you are picked I'd be like send white
powder for the network is there any
concern do you think on Wendy's part
that you do such a great job that Fox
turns around and goes yeah we want to
make this a full-time gig and maybe now
you're either competing or you take her
slot or was no because um there's no way
my ratings will compare to Wendy's
Wendy's my Oprah she's my boss she's I
have meetings with her every day I mean
I really would is Oprah upset at the
success of dr. Phil
no she's cashing those checks all go I
mean his Oprah upset at the success of
dr. oz he was different than her and
you're different than Wendy yeah you're
not somebody that you're not the same
gender the same race you Donald the same
attitude so when you put any someone
who's very different up you're not
competing directly with yourself and
it's funny the stories um the stories
are a little different she gave me some
great advice this is really funny um she
said listen the producers and network
everybody's gonna be getting on you for
this thing you gotta be yourself when
you go out there you got to push all
that to this like take advice and like
terms of format but make sure you don't
change your personality when you go out
there no matter what they say even if
they tell you to change it don't change
it that's good advice and that's when he
does that what I like about Wendy as a
TV host is she kind of has the exact
same vibe that she always had on the
radio where she's not afraid of like
being conversational taking a weird
pause here whatever like it's not this
kind of polished her TV show person
she's actually a communicator well I
mean also I like you know Jim and Jim
you guys as well you've been doing this
you know for a little bit here I'm sure
people have said like oh hey go and do
this and it's maybe felt a little
uncomfortable and now that you've got a
couple miles on your engine and you're
like sort of coasting at a nice place in
your career you've realized I've just
got to be myself I tried doing what they
told me I just couldn't do it like stop
blinking so much and write good jokes
[Laughter]
stop making jokes about having
unprotected sex all the time so then
it's like the would would like a
long-term like goal B to have a TV block
where it's Wendy and then Jerry and
that's like the morning I don't know you
know it's funny that's not my business
like wherever they whatever happens go
on you do the show and and I speak for
itself you know what another thing I
found out is like I have to concentrate
on next week it's I thought I was gonna
you know I like you guys I'm an actor
like that's what I normally do I
actually don't even have the experience
of doing stand-up and stuff so I thought
for sure I was
gonna show up an hour a day and just do
the show and that's not the case it
never is
you tell me one to go yeah and then what
are we talking about the first 10
minutes done and you made plans at your
wive's
we're gonna go to Jersey apple-picking
yeah exactly what's happening right now
I keep telling my wife oh let's go get
lunch and they're like you can't leave
and I have to only keep telling my wife
I can't go get lunch what time do you
stay till about 9:00 last night we got
in at about 7:00 a.m. to 9:00 p.m.
nuts um next week will be seven cuz we
start her a little earlier it's been
about nine
it's post-production stop what a
complain I mean obviously I notice
you're listening to this being like [ __ ]
you man I'm dying
[ __ ] you yeah um but to be fair roofers
you don't have to entertain you don't
have to feel that absolutely shirt off
and throw some tar down one more Jim and
Sam catch up with full episodes and
interviews from celebrity guests anytime
on demand using the Sirius XM app